-♪ "Mad Lib Theater,"
ah, ah, yeah ♪
-[ Laughing ] Yes!
-What?
-That was amazing.
-♪ "Mad Lib Theater" ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-[ Laughs ]
-That was fantastic.
-I loved it.
-All right,
here's how this works.
This is "Mad Lib Theater."
So here, I'm going to ask you
for some silly words.
-Okay.
-Nouns, verbs, adjectives.
And they're going to be written
on cue cards as you say them,
and then we'll act out
a dramatic "Mad Libs" scene.
Are you ready? Here we go.
-Okay. Yes.
-Silly word.
-Gooby...
[ Laughter ]
Gooby gock?
-Gooby gock.
Type of fish.
-Mackerel.
-He's on the show tonight, too.
[ Laughter ]
Adjective.
-Swirling.
[ Light laughter ]
-What you would shout
if you saw a ghost.
-Get out, you!
[ Laughter ]
-A number.
-59.
-Another number.
-2.
-A noun.
-Canoe?
-A body part.
-Achilles' heel.
[ Laughter ]
-Another adjective.
-Uh, drinking.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, oh, adjective.
Sorry.
-Yeah. It's a describer.
-Sorry, sorry.
-No, I'm sorry. It's tough.
-Fluffy.
-Yeah.
That's good.
A type of animal?
-Uh...platypus.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, man.
A curse word that you'd say
in front of a child.
-Um...toot.
[ Laughter ]
-Amount of time,
like two minutes or five hours.
-Oh, um, uh...two...hours.
-Verb ending in "ing."
-Drinking.
-There you go.
Hey, Kristen is playing
the game, okay?
Come on.
-They can help.
-Yeah. They can help, yeah.
Drinking.
Another body part.
-Armpit.
-A verb.
-Hammering.
-Yeah, okay, yeah.
Hammering.
A verb ending in "ing."
Sorry.
-Oh, oh.
Oh, a different one?
-A different one, now.
-Biting.
[ Laughter ]
-Adjective.
-Striped.
-A type of profession.
-A cruise director.
[ Laughter ]
-Cruise director.
Oh, these are great.
Type of relative.
-Second cousin.
Male name.
-Gary.
-Made up song title.
-"Feel My Face."
[ Laughter ]
All right.
We filled out the words
for our scene.
You ready to perform?
-Yes.
-Here we go.
Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, if it isn't
my favorite patient,
Mr. Gooby Gock.
-Thanks for seeing me on such
short notice, Dr. Mackerel.
So, what's the news?
-Well we just finished
processing your test
and unfortunately,
the results are swirling.
-Get out, you!
[ Laughter ]
-I completely understand
that reaction.
Your blood pressure
is 59 over 2.
And our X-rays found a canoe
in your Achilles' heel.
[ Laughter ]
It also appears that you have
a rare condition
known as
Fluffy Platypus Disease.
[ Laughter ]
-Toot!
Is there any way to cure it?
-I'm going to write you
a prescription for these pills
right here
that I have in my pocket.
I want you to take one
every two hours.
-But I heard those pills cause
involuntary drinking.
-I'm afraid they do.
Side effects also include
an itchy armpit
and a decrease in the desire
to hammer.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That a medical term?
Uh wh--
[ Laughter ]
What can I do to stay healthy?
-I would suggest
waking up early...
-[ Laughs ]
-...every morning
and doing stretches
and then biting in the park.
[ Laughter ]
-That's great advice,
especially for a striped
cruise director such as myself.
-You know, the best part
about being a doctor
is that I get to treat
patients like you
and then go home
to my second cousin, Gary...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...and then sing them
my favorite song.
-Which is?
-"Feel My Face."
[ Groans ]
-How does it go?
Can you sing it for me?
[ Laughter ]
"Feel My Face."
-Yes.
♪ You and me gotta get
out of this place ♪
♪ And come back to apartment
so you can feel my face ♪
♪ Touch my body, touch my body ♪
-Thank you very much, doctor.
I appreciate it.
-I'm so sorry.
-Uh, no, please.
And scene.
That is how you do it
right there.
Kristen Wiig!
That's how you do it!